hey you guys doing another movie review
today
going a little bit obscure with this one
maybe um i feel like
i don't know this is one of those movies
that it kind of made a big splash at
least in the sort of art house festival
circuit when it first came out
and then it kind of disappeared for many
years uh it does seem like
in the last few years it's kind of
getting a critical reassessment
i think it only just recently got
released on blu-ray it like disappeared
for many years there was only like a
crappy vhs
and it's just it's crazy this is kind of
like
one of those quintessential cult films
and i feel like a lot of people have not
seen it it's not for everybody i'm not
gonna
say that i guess no movie is like i said
but if you want to watch it at the
moment at least as of this recording
it's actually on 2b in the united states
you can watch it for free
this is the 1990 very weird
film the reflecting skin now
is this a horror film sort of
it's sort of a horror art house sort of
hybrid movie
it really gives me a david lynch kind of
vibe
um a lot of people have compared it to
tideland
by terry gilliam maybe some of terence
malek's earlier films
something like that it is very i've seen
it called prairie gothic
which uh yeah i guess that's pretty
accurate as well but yeah this is uh
a weird ass film and uh it's also
notable
uh not only for being a weird ass film
but also for being
one of the very first starring roles for
a young
vegan mortensen who uh shows up in the
movie about halfway through
so what the hell is this movie about
let's delve into this shall we if you
guys have not seen this i am going to
spoil it so
if you haven't seen it you might want to
go to 2b or whatever uh streaming
service you can find it on and watch it
if you're into surrealism if you're into
art house horror
if you're into just like really creepy
weird like david lynchian kind of [ __ ]
it does have kind of a blue velvet kind
of thing except
more of a rural america thing rather
than a suburban
but if you if that sounds like something
that you can
jive with then go watch and then come
back but like i said i'm going to spoil
pretty much everything that happens in
it and kind of discuss
what what maybe the symbolism is because
there are a couple different
interpretations of this film um but i'm
not really sure which one of them
uh i kind of uh adhere to but we'll kind
of talk about that maybe
in the comments or whatever so as i said
this movie was actually directed by
uh philip ridley who's a british
director i believe this was his first
feature length film he's actually uh
something
of a renaissance man he's actually a
visual artist
that's i believe how he got his start uh
he's also a musician
he's also uh does a [ __ ] ton of stuff in
theater
you know so he's just kind of like
multi-talented all around and he has
made a handful of films over the years
as i said
the reflecting skin being i believe his
first feature length film the
cinematographer on this which i
feel the need to mention because the
cinematography in this
movie is breathtaking was dick pope
who probably best known for all of the
films that he shot with mike lee he
actually did
almost all of his films as far as i
could tell from his wikipedia page this
is not
just doesn't look anything like a mike
lee film but but i just thought that i
would uh you know
point that out he won a lot of awards
for this particular film
now as i said when this movie came out
in 1990
it was sort of the bell of the ball i
believe it was you know
it won all these awards it can and all
these like european film festivals every
saying it was a masterpiece
i actually saw it i'm not really sure
what attracted me to it i think it's
nominally i want to say it's nominally a
vampire
movie but not really which i'll get to
in a little bit i think i saw
the vhs copy in if i'm remembering
correctly in uh
the video store near where i grew up and
i must have seen it in 1991 because i
remember
writing about it and i remember writing
about it in an apartment i used to live
in
in daytona beach behind bel air plaza
the old belair plaza across from
uh the atlantic ocean across from a1a
and uh
i moved out of there in late 1991 so it
must have been 1991 that i saw it i
think what i did for whatever reason
i rented it and i watched it and i
really really dug it because i thought
it was like really
strange and so i made a dupe copy of it
with my because i used to have one of
those
fancy like dual deck vcrs like back in
the early 90s
so i made a copy of it so i watched it
many times over the years
and then i always kind of remembered
some things about it particularly the
opening scene
if you've seen it you will know what i'm
talking about it makes a large
impression
so i remembered that and i remembered a
little bit kind of what the story was
but not exactly
so it was really neat like to watch it
again because i probably i haven't seen
it for probably 20 years at this point
maybe even longer
and i had forgotten a lot of stuff about
it so it was kind of cool
to revisit it so this story is actually
set in a very rural small town
in i believe it's supposed to be idaho
even though the film is actually set in
canada it involves
it i think it's sometime in the 50s like
sometime 1955 somewhere
around there the main character is an
eight or nine year old boy named seth
dove now the family that he lives in
kind of [ __ ] up uh we'll we'll say
that it's kind of like
his mom is very what's the word that i
want to use
she's kind of a lunatic and she's also
very abusive
his dad is uh kind of checked out um
you find out some things about him later
on which i'll get into in a bit
uh but he just doesn't seem all that
involved in uh
the family life in his son's life he's
just kind of keeps to himself
and kind of you know reads his novels
and just wants to
check out of everything which in a way
you can kind of understand
i will say that the first scene now like
i said if you are very very sensitive to
animal cruelty you will probably
the first five minutes of this movie
you'll probably just turn it off you'll
be like yeah no i'm not gonna
which is kind of the impression that it
made wipes it's fake don't worry about
it but
i will say in the very first few minutes
of this movie
seth and two of his terrible little
friends who are also little boys their
names are um
eben and kim and they have a thing where
he finds this enormous he calls it a
frog but it looks like a cane toad i
mean it's
really really big it's a big frog and
they proceed to put a little
pipe like a straw like up its butthole
and they inflate it and then they lay it
in the middle of the road
so that when this woman who's kind of
also lives in the town she's kind of the
town recluse or whatever
when she walks by in the road there's
this big inflated frog
laying there and the kids shoot a
slingshot at it and the frog
explodes all over the woman so
just say that's what you're getting in
for this is like literally the first two
or three minutes of the movie
so these children are kind of horrible
now i will say too that
i don't really think that there is a
likable character
in this entire movie everyone like i
said it's very lynchy and everyone is
just very
there's everyone has just these strange
mannerisms and strange personality
quirks
everyone's kind of terrible i don't know
they're like compelling
nevertheless uh probably viego
mortensen's character whose name is
cameron
he's a seth's older brother and like i
said he doesn't come into the movie
until about halfway through
he's probably the most sympathetic
character but he's got a lot of problems
as well the widow that they
that the frog gets blown up all over her
name is dolphin blue
uh she is also quite sympathetic too but
she's kind of a nutcase
uh so even the sympathetic characters
are kind of loons
you know what i mean so this is just
it's a very very strange movie okay so
you know so you have these boys that
blow this frog up
and so she gets frog blood all over her
and
seth's crazy mom makes him go over to
dolphin blues house to apologize for
blowing the frog up
and as he does that him and dolphin blue
get into this very very strange uh
conversation
now she is a widow her husband
hanged himself about a week after their
funeral i'm not sure
how long it's been since that happened
but she's still in mourning she still
wears black everywhere and she's got
like sunglasses and everything so she's
very striking like walking through these
like bright yellow wheat fields
you know these big vast fields of which
i i believe the director philip ridley
the the legend goes that he would come
to the scene this he would come to the
set like every morning
and spray paint the wheat fields so
they'd be yellower
so look i don't know if that's true or
not because it's a lot of wheat fields i
mean if you see the movie i don't know
if anybody could
spray paint all of that but that's the
story anyway because they are very
like vibrant yellow so uh so she has
lost her husband
and she is still very very uh broken up
about it
so the this whole conversation between
her and the little boy she's basically
saying
things like well she was like well i
didn't so much care about you blowing up
the frog i just didn't like that you got
blood all over my dress and then
she tells them weird [ __ ] like oh have
you ever tied firecrackers to a cat's
tail it's awesome
you should do that so she's a she's a
weird weird lady
and then she starts talking about her
late husband
in this very strange way and she has
this little box
that has all of these kind of mementos
of him there's like a you know little
little bottle of the cologne he used to
wear one of his teeth is in there like
so like a thing of his hair and all this
other kind of stuff
and uh so it's just like this really
weird situation
and the kid says something about like
asking how old she was or she asked him
how old that um that he thought she was
and
he said oh i'm 50 and she said oh i'm
200 years old now obviously if you're an
adult you know she was just
kidding like in a weird way but the
point of this movie
is that everything is seen
through seth's eyes so everything in
this movie that happens
you're not really unsure if it really
happened the way
that it's portrayed or if you're only
seeing it that way
because seth saw it that way as a little
boy because he didn't understand
what was going on he didn't understand
the adult world he didn't understand
the various horrors you know that
happened over the course of the movie
so he was interpreting things in
a way that would be sort of fantastical
to an adult
so let me just get that out of the way
right there
so because of all the weird [ __ ] that
she says
and because a little bit later on one of
his little friends
evan turns up murdered in the water
cistern
in town he starts to suspect
that dolphin blue is a vampire
now he gets this idea because his dad
was reading a book about vampires and
the kid was asking about them and even
the cover on the front of the novel
looks pretty much like a wheat field
with a woman with a black outfit and
black sunglasses stuff looking very much
like dolphin blue and it's like about
it's called vampire blood or
something like that and she's kind of
like beckoning to a kid
so so again it's it seems like on the
nose but
remember that you're seeing things
through his eyes or how he's remembering
them perhaps
um because i've seen some people say
that this whole movie might be
him as an adult remembering back to this
particular summer in 1955
and filtering everything through that
lens where he didn't really understand
anything that was going on
so he becomes convinced that dolphin
blue is a vampire and is starting to
kill
all his little friends now
when eben turns up dead uh
the first person that the sheriff
suspects is actually seth's dad
and the reason that he has for
suspecting him is one that eben was
found on their
property like on their farm in their
water cistern
and also because at some point in the
past seth's dad
was caught kissing a 17 year old
boy i'm not sure how long ago this was i
don't know
if he was much older than 17 or
something like that but like i said this
is the 50s and it's a very very rural
area
so anything that smacks of you know not
being straight uh is gonna be like hey
you must be a murderer
so you know so at this point because the
dad gets
uh blamed for the murder and everybody
in town kind of thinks that he's the one
that did it
he kills himself by drinking
gasoline out of the tank at his gas
station because that's what his family
does they run a gas station
and then pouring gasoline all over
himself and lighting a match so
self-immolation so he basically blows up
the whole gas station
and seth sees the whole thing happen so
he sees his dad blow himself up
like in front of his face so as i said
you're having all these horrific things
happen
where you know first he sees he talks to
dolphin blue about
you know the suicide of her husband and
she's kind of talking about that and
talking about grief
and telling him about evil and things
like that
then one of his friends turns up dead
then his dad blows himself
up his mom like i said is also very
abusive she does things like
you know like one time he leaves the
light on like a little bit too late and
she like smacks him around and
makes him keep drinking water but not be
but not pee she's basically
waterboarding him [ __ ] like that she's
just like a lunatic
so it's just this crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] so
after his dad dies
his brother cameron who's played by vega
mortensen
uh comes home from the army to kind of
take care of the family because the mom
has just like completely checked out and
now she's like a complete
nut um you know so and you know there's
no dad so
seth needs somebody to look after him so
cam comes home now cam
has been i guess he's been in the
pacific
and he participated in some of the like
atomic bomb tests and things like that
so he's kind of [ __ ] up too because
he's seen
some super [ __ ] up [ __ ] so he's not
really the same either when he comes
back these everyone in this movie
is like a broken person in some way
so even though seth is kind of like
looking up to his brother and hoping
that now there'll be some restoration of
normalcy um
obviously that is not gonna happen
because like i said cam is kind of
[ __ ] up
he's normal sometimes but then uh you
know the whole title the reflecting skin
kind of comes from one scene where
cam is showing seth like some pictures
that he
took over there and there was this one
picture of a baby
i don't know if it was alive or dead but
it had some kind of radiation sickness
and its
uh face he said it was the face was like
reflecting like a mirror and you could
see yourself in it
and so they're kind of using that as a
symbol
not only you know the baby had
reflective skin but also
vampires maybe could have reflective
skin vampires can't be seen in mirrors
and then there's also the thing of seth
reflecting the world through his
sort of broken innocence i guess because
this is kind of the summer where
he went from a child who didn't
understand anything and then all these
horrific things happened
and it sort of invaded his childhood and
made him grow up really quickly
but he sees everything through i guess a
mirror
reflection of his naivet naivete i guess
is is one way of putting it i i forgot
to mention earlier that a few times
during the movie
there has been like all these kind of
greaser looking dudes
and they're driving around town in this
black cadillac
um and they seem a little bit menacing a
little you know what i mean
so that's that's another thing that's
going on in the background that you have
to
you know take into account so after
camera comes back
uh him and seth are visiting seth's
dad's grave
uh their dad's grave and dolphin is
there as well
and dolphin blue and cam kind of
start taking a hanker into each other
you know they they kind of fall in love
now seth of course is horrified by this
because he believes
that dolphin blue is a vampire and that
she is going to drain his life force
this is reinforced because as i
mentioned earlier
because cam had been involved in all of
these atomic bomb tests in the pacific
he has radiation sickness so a little
bit he doesn't look too bad but his hair
is falling out
his gums are bleeding he's losing weight
so of course seth doesn't know
that he has radiation sickness so he
interprets this as
dolphin blue is draining your life force
so basically this kid
is seeing everything that he doesn't
understand and casting it in a
supernatural
kind of light you know what i mean i
think kind of the theme of the movie and
i was watching a video earlier
where he kind of where he was kind of
breaking down the philosophy behind this
and he's like basically there's during
this first conversation that dolphin
blue and seth have
she says something to the effect of
sometimes evil happens quite naturally
or something like that which i think is
almost kind of like the movie's mission
statement because i think the movie
is kind of showing that if you're a
child or someone that's very
superstitious
you always want to attribute these
horrific things that happen
evil things that happen to something
outside
of us something outside of humans so
something supernatural
but the movie is is showing that
it doesn't need to be supernatural
humans do horrible things all they're
all on their own so we have to like move
past this childlike
you know vision of the world where
everything has to be caused by an
outside force you know because humans
are terrible enough on their own which
you know
that's a cheerful message isn't it but
so because he believes
that dolphin blue is a vampire and
because he believes
that she is the one responsible for
killing his
friend evan who i neglected to mention
this is so weird there's a movie it's
like if you describe what happens in it
people like think you're [ __ ] high or
you're making it up but seriously this
does happen in the movie
at some point seth and his friend kim
they find in a barn i'm not really sure
how it got there
but it's sort of like this ossified
fenus if fetus it's like a dead baby
but it's like it's not mummified it's
almost kind of like i don't know it's
like really weird
and he and they find it and for some
reason
seth starts to believe that this
dead baby is eben
like in a incarnated angel form so he
takes
the dead baby home keeps that under his
bed and like talks to it at night
as though it's his friend evan okay so i
forgot to mention that there's all kind
of weird
details in this [ __ ] i've even mentioned
like the two twins like talking like
birds or anything
it's just like there's so much bizarre
[ __ ] in this it's like hard to
you know keep track of it all so the
thing about it is that even
so he believes that dolphin blue is
killing you knows killed his friends
is draining his brother's life force but
then the weird thing is that he sees
with his own two eyes the um
aforementioned greasers in the black
cadillac
kidnapping his other friend kim who
later turns up dead
now there is some speculation because i
don't believe
anyone else in the movie ever sees the
black cadillac or ever interacts with
the dudes in the black cadillac except
for dolphin blue so some people have
speculated
that the greasers and the black cadillac
are actually
not there that they're actually a
manifestation of seth's
imagination and that in fact seth killed
his friends
uh and is kind of casting back you know
a laying
guilt for his crimes by saying that it
was like someone else that did it was
this gang
but yeah so they kidnapped him put him
in the car and then later on he turns up
dead as well
now at this point as i said he has this
huge argument with
uh cam because he's telling us like look
dolphin blue she's a vampire she's
draining your life force that's why all
these bad things are happening to you
that's why you're losing weight and your
hair is falling out and all this other
kind of stuff
and huge of course just laughs at it
she's like look you know i'm in love
with her she's in love with me we're
running away together we need to get the
[ __ ] out of this place
and uh so he is kind of you know fails
in
trying to save his brother but then like
right at the end
seth sees her and she is wearing white
now
uh meaning that she has moved past the
grief over her husband she's done
mourning
and she's ready to move on with her new
life with cam
and she comes toward him and she says a
few things about
growing old and um you know she's like
when you get older you know this will
happen you'll get arthritis and you'll
[ __ ] yourself and you know all your
teeth will fall out and all these other
things
she's like but so she has this long
litany of like all those horrible things
that happen to you like while you're
aging
but then at the end she says but if you
find somebody
to love you then it's okay then you'll
always be young
so she kind of says something like that
and then she says to him that she's
going into town
and she needs a ride at which point the
greasers in the black cadillac
drive by and she gets in the car with
them
now even though seth has seen
uh these dudes whether they're real or
not has seen these dudes
uh kidnap his friend who later turned up
dead he does not warn her
that they are murderers so she gets in
the car
all smiles and then later on she is
found dead
laying in the cornfield uh at which
point cameron
of course has a nervous breakdown and
the very very last scene of the film
is seth finally realizing that
she is not a vampire that none of the
stuff that has happened
none of the horrific events that have
taken place have been attributable to a
supernatural force that it was a human
force
so it's almost like he kind of grows up
all in this one day
and he just runs out into the cornfield
at sunset and he just screams and
screams and screams at the sunset and
then he has like all this dirt falling
which goes back to something that uh his
dad was saying about
you know you need to drink something or
you'll be dust or whatever and like i
said it that kind of goes back to the
vampire thing too
because you know vampires turning to
dust in the sun
but basically it's him coming to terms
with
humans can be evil that that's all that
evil is it's just
horrible things that humans do to one
another you don't need a supernatural
aspect
and the fact that he did not warn
dolphin blue
um or in some interpretations that he
may be killed dolphin blue
and just as i said maybe those dudes
aren't real and maybe seth was the one
doing all the murders
um but he's kind of just come to realize
that his brother's life
is destroyed now you know everything
like every
horrible thing from the adult world has
come crashing in on his
childhood innocence so as i said this um
this movie it's very very strange it's
kind of like the
one of the quintessential cult films and
i think it's one that was kind of a
little bit
forgotten about i don't think like i
said i think it came out
it made a big splash when it came out as
i said on the festival circuit but then
it sort of
went away and like nobody really talked
about it for a really long time
and then i guess on the internet some
people started talking about especially
because of that you know exploding frog
thing in the front because that was
certainly the uh the scene that made the
biggest impression on me
um you know and i still remembered it
after all that time
and so i feel like it kind of got a
little bit rediscovered and it got
uh you know because for a long time it
was only on vhs
and then there was kind of like i think
there was a japanese dvd or a blu-ray or
something but it was kind of crappy
quality
i think 2015 i think they finally
released it on blu-ray although i
believe it's limited
edition but yeah i mean this is a
gorgeous looking movie
uh the director philip ridley uh has
said that
he you know even though he's british he
had uh you know seen a lot of american
films obviously and read a lot of
american literature
and wanted the film to look like kind of
an american gothic like you know the
paintings of andrew wyeth or edward
hopper
something like that this actually kind
of reminds me a little bit
it has a little bit of the same vibe as
the other
from 1972 you know by thomas tryon
which um you know we did a retrospective
on a while back but
in the sense that it's just this very
very rural
setting and just like this golden color
palette
with um you know all of this you know
this almost kind of like idyllic
gorgeous looking surface and all of this
you know sort of rot going on underneath
it so you know that's very much the
theme of the whole thing like i said
more that humans are the cause of evil
instead of like supernatural
now as i said i don't know this it's
very very arthouse
it's kind of slow moving i guess
but it just has so many weird scenes
and just so many like disturbing images
like a lot of
[ __ ] up stuff happens in this and i've
even watched like some reviews of it
by younger reviewers that were like man
that was
[ __ ] up there's like [ __ ] up stuff
happens in this so i'm just saying that
but i'm just saying that if you're into
more like traditional horror i guess you
probably
won't be into it you might just think
it's weird or boring or something like
that
but it's just really it's it's a hard to
describe
film if you haven't seen it but yeah
it's still
it's on 2b at the moment as i said i
think there's a special edition blu-ray
that came out in 2015 although
i think it was limited edition so i
don't know if there's any of those left
or not
but i definitely would recommend it
especially if you're into
just real uh you know kind of if you're
into like if you
if you like stories like you know
flannery o'connor or something like that
um or you liked david lynch like some of
david lynch's movies you would probably
really dig this it's super super weird
um not a horror movie necessarily but
it's kind of like
a weird arty i don't even know if i'd
call it a drama because that makes it
sound too
pedestrian i suppose it's just a very
weird
surreal you know it's very terry gilliam
very
it's it's just along that line so if you
like stuff like that and you haven't
seen it
then i would definitely recommend
checking it out because i feel like it's
still a little bit under the radar a lot
of people don't really talk that much
about it
but yeah it's on 2b at the moment if you
want to check it out so
that'll do it for this flickers of fear
and i will see you on the next one
bye